(audience cheering)
- Rock and roll number.
- I am freaking out.
- [Kelly] Oh, really?
- It is so nice to meet you.
- Me too, I want one in my size.
- Well, you're welcome to anything I have.
I feel like I owe you
everything, you're the greatest.
- Oh, you're so nice. Well,
the feeling is mutual.
You did scare me in "Get Out.
- I'm so sorry.
- I was like,
is she scary in real life?
Because that movie scared me tremendously.
So, you're in a new scary movie though.
But before we get there,
what were the holidays like?
Do you like the holiday time?
- I mean, what if I was like,
no, they're terrible, I hate them.
- Some people don't.
- I know, I get it.
- It stresses them out.
- My late grandmother
really didn't like them. I love them.
I love being with family,
I love the food element,
it's always great.
Andy and Anderson. I mean,
it's not New Year's unless
they are doing their thing.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And we're celebrating. So, yeah.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- How was yours?
- Mine was good, mine
was good. I escaped to,
I have a place in Montana, a little ranch.
So, it's like snowy, looks like Narnia.
- Where? I mean, don't
tell me the address.
- I'll tell you on the commercial break.
(both laughing)
- I grew up going there. I love it there.
- [Kelly] Oh, really?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, I love it. It's magical.
And it's nice to get, like I
have kids, so six and eight,
so it's nice to get them
out of the city, but yeah.
And then we went to New
York for little a bit..
It's like the most
beautiful place ever to go.
- Gorgeous, man.
- Yeah.
They light up everything.
Everything's so pretty.
But we're celebrating
self-care for the New Year.
That we're totally all
gonna stick to this time.
- 100%. These resolutions,
we're still going strong.
- These are gonna work.
(audience clapping)
What are some that you have?
Or what's like a resolution?
What's something you wanna do for you?
- Historically, I have been
so terrible about these.
I forget them like a couple
days into the New Year.
This year's hydration.
I'm setting the bar like reasonably low.
And my thinking behind that
is just that it's achievable.
- Do you not drink water?
- I don't. What if I was like I've never.
No, I drink water, just
not, I don't think,
in a life preserving quantity.
- My manager doesn't do
this. I get onto her.
She just does not drink water.
I'm like, how are you not drinking water?
- It's just there's no, it's like.
- I love water.
- There's no taste. That's
a good thing. You're alive.
(Kelly laughing)
- You're alive.
- I drink it because
occasionally my body is like,
"I'm a raisin and you need to hydrate me."
And I'm like, okay. But I'm not like,
you know those people with
the gigantic Hydro Flasks
that's like, there's like levels?
And I look at that and I'm like,
in a month I don't drink that much water.
You have one of those?
- I drink so much water.
- Wow. Good for you.
Anyway, that's my whole,
you already are living my
goal for this entire year.
- So wait, you're parents are journalists.
And your dad is Brian Williams,
for those who don't know.
I didn't know that at first.
(audience clapping)
- [Allison] There they are.
Oh, my mom is so pretty.
- I actually brought it up
because I actually didn't know that
until like going, like deep diving on you
before interviewing you.
- That probably means you have a mind
that is unburdened by a
lifetime of watching news.
- Yes. So wait, so when you told them
that you wanted to be an actress,
what was their take on that?
'Cause I get very
nervous, like with my kids
even like wanting to get in the industry.
It's a hard industry.
- Totally. I think their
initial reaction was like,
as you well know, we kind
of come out as we are.
And then it's about just
assessing like who is this person?
It was very clear to them very
early that I was a performer.
I think they were hoping
I wouldn't figure it out
for as long as possible.
But then when I saw "The Wizard of Oz",
I was like, oh my God,
that person is playing
that role and that role.
When I figured out that that
was a job, it was curtains.
That's all I wanted.
- Yeah.
- My parents were like,
okay, let's think fast.
How do we delay this
for as long as possible?
And they said to me, "We
are gonna support you.
We believe in you. Can we
please give you the honor
of a college education
and ask that you delay it
for as long as possible?
We're buying ourselves to at least 22"
and I said yes, because I was wise enough
to take them up on that offer.
And so, I went to college.
- 'Cause that's a blessing
to have college paid for.
- I think so, too. Of course.
Yeah, I mean, I feel very
lucky for all aspects of it.
I definitely wouldn't have
been ready any younger
to be in this business, it's a wild ride.
And so that was how they reacted.
With like support and skepticism,
and let's just put this
off as long as possible.
- That's good parenting though. Yeah.
- [Allison] I think so too.
- Yeah.
- I mean, you can assess
at the end of this
if you think they did a god
job. (everyone laughing)
- I will do, my glasses
on with my notebook.
- Exactly, you're like,
they messed this up royally.
- No, I do think, I mean,
I think it's different
for all people or
whatever, but I think that
that is a good, I was
19 and that was hard.
- I forget that you were 19.
- I was 19, so that was hard, I think.
But at least I was out of high school.
Like, I think even like
when people start young
I'm like, ooh. That's a hard thing.
- But no matter how old you are,
it's hard to wrap your head around.
So I figure like they were right.
With every year that you put it off,
your brain chemistry is a little bit more
complete and developed.
- Developed. Yeah.
I agree. I agree.
- [Allison] Okay, good.
- Do they watch everything you do?
- They do. They're
really supportive, yeah.
When I was on "Girls", I
got this question a lot.
And it like made people
feel extremely weird,
because that show was,
why'd you have to bring
them back for this?
(everyone laughing)
That show had a lot of sex on it.
- [Kelly] You're scary as hell.
- Yeah I was scary. That I think like,
luckily they understand me, but you know,
"Girls" was like, but yes,
they are very supportive.
They watch everything I do.
We have it down to kind of a science.
On "Girls", by the time we had finished,
I'd be like, okay, I got the
episodes for this season.
There will be six sex scenes,
they're gonna be in these episodes.
- You have a break down?
- Exactly.
Just to be like, here's how you need
to dose out your adrenaline
for the whole couple months.
- Here's when you fast forward.
- Exactly. Exactly. Yeah.
- [Kelly] So I love
the support though too.
- Oh, I feel so lucky. Are you kidding?
- And those are grown adults
that can handle that too.
That's nice. That's a healthy family.
- And we all, I mean,
like the whole bunch,
our whole family, we all
went to the "M3gan" premiere,
for example, a couple weeks ago.
And all six of us are kind
of in various versions
of this business, from
one angle or another.
So the joke I our house is like,
if you need a makeup wipe,
all of us have a solution.
Every one of us. My brother's on TV,
my dad's on TV, my mom is a producer,
my sister-in-law is also
like, in the business.
And my partner is an actor.
So if you need to remove makeup,
if you need a makeup suggestion,
there are five other people in our house
who can give you advice.
- You're covered.
You're covered.
- Yeah, you are covered.
Exactly.
- That's kind of cool
that you're all in the
business in some form.
That's kind of nice 'cause you understand.
- Yeah. Exactly.
- Yeah.
You understand the demand
and that support system is awesome.
(audience cheering)
- All right,
so the new movie is called "M3gan".
And it's about an
artificial intelligence doll
that kind of goes evil, right?
- Yeah, well you kind of know.
Like you see her face. You see the poster.
You're like, this is not a comedy.
(audience laughing)
But it's very funny.
It's like dark humor, I promise.
So, I hear we are very similar
in terms of how we can
tolerate scary movies.
- I don't do scary.
- Me neither.
I really can't. The affect me so much.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- So I am telling you that
there are a few moments
that are like, jump scares.
But for the most part,
- God, I hate that.
- If you're in a theater, it's like
from the premiere I know,
there's like laughing, cheering, clapping.
It's like one of those
communal movie experiences.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Allison] She is fun.
- [Allison] It ends up,
I promise, being fun. But yeah.
So my character is a roboticist
who's come up with this doll
who's kind of the ideal like companion
for a kid slash parent ally.
Who can remind them to, for
example, flush the toilet.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Rather than a parent
having to say, flush the toilet.
- A billion times.
- I didn't know that little kids
just love to go to the bathroom,
hate to deal with the consequences.
- And just leave it in there,
by the way.
- Walk away, yep.
- And then the smell just,
and they close the door
and it's like nice.
- It breathes like a wine.
Exactly. So imagine that you had an AI
who could just stand on
the outside of the bathroom
and be like, did you flush? And
then they go back and flush.
Did you wash your hands?
Did you roll up your sleeves?
Did you dry your hands?
All of that stuff.
- But this goes poorly.
- Yeah, weirdly enough.
Who could've guessed?
It doesn't go super well, no.
- What if, okay wait,
so if you could use
artificial intelligence,
like to make your life
easier, what would you do?
'Cause mine would be
a masseuse. (laughing)
- That sounds kind of kinky.
- My body. (laughing)
I didn't go there.
- That sounds all-purpose.
Listen, if it happens, it happens.
- Look, I don't know
how to talk about that.
I'm on daytime right now.
- I'm so sorry.
- No, no.
- It's too early.
- No, but I will say, whatever.
But no, I find myself, I'm
40, like and I find myself
I just, I feel broken sometimes.
And I started Pilates.
And did all the things.
A million things. But
like I just feel broken.
- I love the way you say
Pilates with such disgust.
You're like Pilates.
- I actually love Pilates, but I'm like
it's just such a cliche,
you get to a certain age
and you're like, "I'm go to Pilates."
I'm like, you know, it's yeah.
- You do that hand movement?
- And I do the, yeah.
Stretch it out. But it is wonderful.
But I find that my body always hurts,
so I'd have a masseuse.
- You'd have a masseuse.
That's a really good idea.
- What about you? What would you do?
- I would, so even though
for my entire life,
three times a day, I've had
to eat, I forget every time,
until it's like an hour
after I'm starving hungry.
- I do this.
- And I'm like,
what is food? What is food preparation?
What is planning? What's
the approach here?
Just someone to just
remind me that it's coming.
- I'm bad at that too.
I think you're too busy.
- Yeah, exactly. I get like
wrapped up in something.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And you're hungry.
And then, I mean, if we're in
a world where we're dreaming,
it's also preparing the food for me.
(audience laughing)
Because even sometimes
when you're that hungry,
like a mac and cheese seems
kind of insurmountable.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Yes.
- It's hilarious to me
how many cooking demos I do on this show.
- [Allison] I know.
- And I'm not a cook.
- I know. I know.
- It's ironic. Really.
- I relate to you in that way.
- Oh yeah. Me too.
So wait so you'll have to
start making kid movies though
because, so when I started having kids,
I started doing, like I wrote books,
I like started quilting, I
started doing all these things
that I never thought I'd do.
- No, I haven't entered that stage yet.
- They're not good.
They're not great quilts.
Don't look closely. Don't look closely.
But I started doing things
that were like different
for me in general.
And reaching one?
- Just turned, yeah
he's a little over one.
- [Kelly] That's exciting.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, so what is it like?
What do you think mother,
I think motherhood totally,
it doesn't change you,
you still have your identity,
but it does bring different
parts of you out, I feel like.
- Oh yeah. There's no part
of it that I was like,
I nailed that in my anticipation.
(Kelly laughing)
I knew exactly what that would be like.
Like from the beginning
of the whole experience,
all of it is surprising.
But I have found it to be,
I don't know, I get
really shy, first of all,
talking about, I don't know why,
I feel like shy talking about it.
- Oh that's okay.
- It's this new part of me
I like haven't figured out how to assess.
I kind of want to wait a
couple years and be like,
what do you think of me?
How am I doing?
- Yeah, ask the kid.
- Yeah, could you write an evaluation?
- Did I do all right?
- What do you think of my service?
They have the little like
smiley faces in hospitals.
- One to five.
- Yeah, exactly.
No, it's changed every
part of me, I think.
- One is, that's still really young.
Like you're still kind of like
going through the motions.
You're sleeping though, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. We got that.
- That's the hardest part is like,
somebody told me about sleep training
and it saved me.
- [Allison] Did that.
- Especially for working parents.
- Yes very hard. You gotta have sleep.
- If you weren't an actress,
also if you just wanna do on the side,
you would be an amazing comedian.
Your timing is so funny.
Your comedic timing.
(audience clapping)
- That's so nice. Thank you.
- I'm like laughing this whole interview.
I was like, she's really funny.
- I feel the same way about,
I'm so happy you're doing this.
- [Kelly] Oh, thank you.
- You are made to do a lot
of things in this world.
(audience clapping)
This is one of them.
- Thank you. I enjoy it.
But I'm just saying, you're hilarious.
We're gonna stop for a quick break though.
"M3gan" is in theaters now.
If you like to be scared, go see it.